JESSICA: Last year, we
introduced Android for Work,
a new way to make
Android awesome at work
for employees and businesses.
In Lollipop, we put some
sugar-coated efforts
into making Android devices
suitable for managed
deployments.
IT admins can now securely
deploy company-owned devices.
They can also support bring
your own device, or "BYOD."
I'm Jessica.
I'm going to tell you how
we've enhanced Android for Work
in the M release with even more
APIs for device administration,
a better, more polished BYOD
experience, and an entirely
new way to deploy
devices called "COSU."
More about that later, but
if you build or deploy apps
for business, you will
want to watch this video.
Here's a quick recap
for those of you
who don't already know all
about Android for Work.
Millions of people are
bringing their own devices
to the workplace.
In Android Lollipop, they can
set up a secure work profile
managed by their IT admin.
The work profile contains
apps and data that
are separately administered.
Users just install their
company's Enterprise Mobility
Management app and sign in.
Hooray.
another acronym-- "EMM."
We've partnered
with some great EMMs
to bring Android for Work
solutions to the market.
We also added a
way for companies
to deploy corporate-owned
devices on L.
We call this model Device Owner.
And it's perfect
for when IT requires
control over the whole device.
All this is pretty much business
as usual for the employee.
Once they've enrolled
their personal device,
they see a Workbench
version of the Play Store.
Here, they can download
enterprise apps
that were approved
by their employer.
Personal and work apps
are available side
by side in the launcher.
Work apps and notifications
are batched so they're
instantly recognizable.
So let's move to the new
APIs in the M release.
IT admins need to keep a handle
on the amount of mobile data
work apps are using.
So we've added a new network
usage API for the work profile.
IT can even break down
data usage by app.
Admins can spend
an enormous amount
of time configuring access
to corporate resources
for each device.
Well, we've addressed
this issue with a new API
that can install certificates
from an IT-approved app.
So now users just enter
corporate credentials once,
and work apps have the
necessary certificates
to access resources securely.
To make life easier
for IT, they now
have the ability to add
read-only Wi-Fi configurations
on corporate-owned devices.
This way, they
can ensure devices
get on the corporate
network with no hassle
or accidental deletions.
It will also reduce the
volume of support requests.
Work should never get
in the way of using
the device you know and love.
So we've made a few
improvements to work
profiles to make the BYOD
experience in M even better.
Firstly, with both personal and
work apps on the same device,
users will now see a work
icon in the status bar
so they know when
they're in a work app.
Secondly, apps that set up
virtual private networks
are popular with consumers
and used in business.
IT will often deploy a VPN
app into the work profile
to provide secure access
to corporate services.
VPN apps will now appear in a
unified settings control panel.
We've refined the
user experience
so corporate VPN
apps are clearly
shown alongside personal ones.
Finally, we've enhanced
the contacts provider.
Now work contact names can be
made available to system apps,
so no more mystery
calls from your boss.
You'll see your boss's name
instead of just a number.
So far, we looked at how to
make life easier for IT admins
and better for users.
Now let's talk about an exciting
new use for Android devices.
Have you ever checked in
for a flight, rented a car,
or ordered room service?
Wouldn't it be
great if you could
do that from a securely managed
Android device in the terminal,
at a kiosk, or in
your hotel room?
Android for Work now lets
IT manage these devices.
We call them COSU--
Corporate-Owned Single-Use
devices.
In one single provisioning
step, such as an NFC bump,
IT can now set up a new
device and lock it to an app.
Device owners can use new
APIs to manage apps on devices
like these in public spaces.
That's about it for our update
on Android for Work in M.
I really hope these work-related
goodies make you as excited
as we are.
Our job is to make your job
just a little bit easier
by making Android even
more tasty at work.
My name is Jessica.
Thanks for watching.
I'd better get back to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]